[Music]
imagine living in a city where you can
afford beautiful homes
a city that combines quality with
affordability
around the world this idea of a liveable
city increasingly seems like a pipe
dream
[Music]
housing unaffordability is not just a
crisis for the united states you see it
in cities as diverse as caracas
moscow rio de janeiro
the un estimates that despite the
pandemic over 60 percent of the world's
population will live in cities by 2030
urbanization is going to keep growing at
a tremendous rate and so we're really
going to need to look at how do we build
in a manner that's livable it's
affordable
there is somewhere though that seems to
be keeping the housing crisis at bay
the austrian capital vienna is one of
the most affordable major cities in the
world it also tops the charts for
quality of life
and how they got there may offer up some
tips for cities globally
[Music]
this is aspen zesta in the suburbs of
vienna
one of the largest new urban
developments currently under
construction in europe zeisterat is
being built on a former airfield and has
a man-made swimming lake at its center
60 to 70 of the apartments built here
will be allocated to affordable housing
some of which are designed by their
occupants
we all know how tough it is
to bring new urban quarters to life to
make them feel like the old parts of the
city that have this patina that we all
love so we introduce
a new model of collaborative housing
self-developed multi-family housing
originated in berlin and fryeburg uh
sort of emanating from the squatters
movements these are groups of people and
oftentimes families or people who are
organized around a certain ideology like
the environment or living in solidarity
they will work to design and build their
own multi-family housing
collaborative housing is one of the
innovative ways subsidized apartments
are being built in vienna now
apart from being something really
special of having the opportunity to
design your own apartment within a
subsidized housing project
what is very important about these
projects is that they think about so
many things they will introduce
regularly co-working spaces
rooms for seminars or a big kitchen that
can be used by everybody
but the most important part is that
these people that have worked together
on designing their own apartments in
their own building form a community a
lively community
so we have found out that they work as a
community magnet and they are the ones
that will bring
life to a new urban quarter
when it comes to affordability seistat
is not an exception
vienna is growing rapidly and to meet
the demand every year it builds at least
seven thousand affordable housing units
about half of all the apartments built
in the city
62 percent of the viennese population
already live in this type of
accommodation
public housing blocks which are
apartments that belong entirely to the
city of vienna are just one part of the
affordable housing portfolio
the city's been building them at a
steady pace since the 1920s
many other countries also tried to make
this model work but few have succeeded
[Music]
public housing summons his vision of
cold monstrous towers
many were at the time of their
construction following world war ii very
utopian projects their planners imagined
a kind of modernist egalitarian society
which might have succeeded if
they
were funded and maintained and and
supported but they were not in the
united states the result is that you
have public housing units that lack
heating and public housing units that
are just not safe
for the occupants
compounded by the racial composition of
public housing residents this has this
deeply troubling implications
you have both quality of life issues and
then general bias and discriminatory
attitudes toward their residents that
mean that people perceive public housing
as a a threat unfortunately
the stigma of public housing has
translated into u.s policy and a rule
called the fair cloth amendment
currently caps the number of public
housing units at the level it was in
1999
municipalities need to either sell or
demolish existing buildings to build new
ones
and this is all compounded by
restrictive zoning laws
when you have
neighborhoods or parts of entire cities
that are zoned for single-family homes
those neighborhoods are effectively
segregated by controlling the nature of
construction through zoning codes you
limit how much housing
can be made anywhere that has had the
result of not a single u.s county having
enough affordable housing for its
current population right now
in the 90s vienna also took a radical
decision about its public housing but
the city went in the opposite direction
public housing was always well
maintained and high quality but to
maximize its investment vienna decided
to instead focus on a model offering
subsidies to private non-profit
companies to build what they call social
housing
the entire model of subsidized housing
in vienna
is very robust and it is very profitable
for the corporations that engage in it
it works on the basis of a three-fold
subsidy affordable housing stands and
falls with land prices so the city of
vienna has a very active land policy
buying
land or mobilizing
historical land reserves and then
either selling it or leasing it to
non-for-profit corporations at a very
very low
affordable price the companies get
subsidised loans for construction and if
the apartments are still too expensive
there are subsidies for renters
what is special about vienna is that
social housing is a middle-class subsidy
it is not thought to be
only for people that
have a weak social economic background
it is thought to be actually for almost
everybody
and as your income increases as you get
older you aren't pushed out of your
social housing and what this does is it
keeps people
in these communities so it's a very
different way of
looking at keeping communities intact
in the 90s the construction process also
changed each company that wants to build
social housing needs to submit their
design in a developer competition
one of the
most important mechanisms of ensuring
sustainability and quality are
competitions
[Music]
the designs are judged based on the
architectural quality of the development
the economic function of the building so
that's how affordably they can build it
the environmental performance of the
building as well as the social mix and
so this is just ensuring there's a
diversity of unit types so it's not just
singles or couples you get families you
have elderly residents
the competitive aspect of the developer
competitions definitely pushes people to
be more innovative on a number of fronts
they're really well designed high
quality buildings low energy buildings
just wonderous amenities saunas
kindergartens clinics libraries
community spaces we almost always have
balconies and in many cases there are
even swimming pools on the rooftops
[Music]
developer competitions are also one of
the main factors driving down the costs
of construction the construction costs
in vienna are about half of what they
are in seattle and so you're getting
these incredible high quality buildings
for really a fraction of what we would
pay here in the u.s
for what i would say are buildings that
are not as
well done
[Applause]
another key element to making this model
work is using space wisely
it would be a waste
of money
to
embark into subsidized housing and then
do low density of course you have to do
high density because this results in
many many more apartments to the benefit
of many many more young families
but
density will work well
only if you combine it with high quality
and i'm talking about high architectural
quality i'm talking about high level
public transport access and i'm talking
about vast green spaces
so the way we go about density is to
create really vast accessible parks and
to concentrate construction at the edges
of these parks they don't have a
significant number of high-rises but
there is this broad density the core is
you know five to eight stories
for kilometers and kilometers in every
direction
today vienna invests in a mix of public
and subsidized housing but just building
new apartments isn't enough
the city is also committed to actively
maintaining and retrofitting its stock
of over 500 000 affordable flats
there's this process in vienna called
the gentle urban renewal
and what this is is the city will go
into neighborhoods where gentrification
is becoming more mainstream and the
effects of it are becoming more visible
they will upgrade the social housing to
ensure that it maintains a similar
quality to the new market rate housing
they will develop amenities to ensure
that you know schools don't become
overcrowded they'll add a floor or two
to the roof of a building this could
become either market rate or social
housing what this does is it allows more
people to live in the neighborhood it
subsidizes the cost of the energetic
retrofit because there's also the
energetic component as well and so
they'll rehabilitate the facade of a
building they'll add ventilation to
ensure that these buildings are
comfortable there aren't mold issues
they're healthy so the city is really
taking an active approach in ensuring
that these buildings are comfortable
habitable
and also climate proof
in the wake of the pandemic the
affordability crisis in cities worldwide
has become even more visible
bran always eats first that means that
medical care
clothing even food um are costs that
renters sacrifice in order to keep a
home over their family's head during the
pandemic they're the kind of plight of
uh low-income tenants really expanded
because the number of people who are out
of work just just ballooned and suddenly
households were confronting
precarity in their housing for the first
time
vienna's model isn't a solution that can
easily be copy and pasted
but other cities are paying attention
[Music]
it will take more than just changes in
policy though
attitudes about how and where we live
will need to shift too
in the u.s there's a lot of desire to
live in a detached house own a single
car for families like mine where we
don't own a car
we have two children we get around by
bike it's density
and ample social housing that really
allows for that kind of lifestyle
there is this generational flip where
families like ours and especially those
that are younger than us have no shot at
affordable housing or market rate
housing in a lot of cities and i think
that we're going to see places really
start to look at adding a density and
hopefully in a smart way that doesn't
bring more cars more congestion so it's
more sustainable in the future
vienna is doing things that everyone
should be aiming for
you